[Music]
you're gonna have a free government
you're gonna have to have a form of the
government because a free government
requires a lot of people participate in
the government the government have to
participate in the government and to do
that you have to have a form you have to
have some established way by which
people participate it has to stay the
same over time or else they'll be
changing it all the time and then soon
enough just a few will run it well our
Constitution is the most successful
thing like that in human history and
decent things like that have been known
since the ancient world none has lasted
so long as ours the Constitution is
authoritative or it's supposed to be and
so why would the Declaration of
Independence matter
my own belief is that you would never
give a full account of the United States
of America without a rich understanding
of those two things and the relationship
between them one of them being the
formal cause of the United States of
America and one of them being the final
cause
[Music]
are you showing off morning okay so
what's the country a country has borders
that's the latest days in it yeah and
okay so that's the edge of a country
what's inside there it's a group of
citizens that have engaged in a contract
together to be ruled by the same
government so it takes contract
according to modern political thought
but there's an interesting sentence in
the Declaration of Independence that we
will read so we can find it so it says
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute new
government laying its foundation on such
principles so we can change the
government it's a right but then what
follows from that kind of a duty to
establish a new set of rules in law so
the Declaration finish doesn't
contemplate life without government does
it right and what's the first objection
against the king he hasn't he hasn't
given those laws he's refused his assent
to laws most wholesome and necessary so
that's like something classical isn't it
because in the classical world mankind
men human beings are the social and
political animals and then they don't
talk of having a right to make a
contract to establish a government and
this does and yet on the other hand this
other thing in here that we need made to
live under law
and it's worth for marking that because
it means we're talking about something
important here at Hillsdale colleges you
all know right you all have different
majors everybody studies everything
fundamental this is something
fundamental you're going to live under
laws because of the kind of thing you
are and if you live under bad laws
you're going to be miserable and it's
very common for people to live under bad
laws and that's one of the points of
this document the Declaration of
Independence we need good laws and if we
don't get them we have a right to rebel
and that means kill the people who deny
them to us which is what they proceeded
to do after this document and the people
were very strong who were ruling America
this he who has refused his assent to
laws the most wholesome and necessary is
a really important guy he's the King of
England the strongest power on earth and
we have a right and a duty to kick him
out of here and we're going to do it so
that's that's what the document is about
what does it say declaration
independence is one of the most
influential documents in all of human
history it gives a picture of the whole
order of nature and it proceeds from
that whole order down finally to what
the class is called the utmost
particular the definite thing to be done
right now how's it begin it begins in
very general terms and that it can be
applied it's not specific to America it
can be applied human events means really
anytime one people the ending people
universally right in that interesting so
who are these guys and where are these
guys when they do this they're all guys
one of them was John Adams who was a
really brilliant and great man but
is brilliant or great as his wife who
gave him happily in writing detailed
advice about everything he did and he
mostly took it really great man
so where are they
apart from the ones that are oppressing
them separated by an ocean yeah I mean
they're when they're right in this
document right they're in Philadelphia
and Philadelphia is on the sea and
Britain is a great sea power risky place
to be
there were people looking for them a
writ had been issued for their arrest
and if they had been found by the army
not a police force they were not gonna
be dragged up in front of local courts
independent from the king they were
gonna be taken back to England ripped
from their families months away right to
be tried in front of strangers which is
what was going on which is one of the
complaints in the middle and what's
interesting about this is they begin to
universally but how does it end let's
look at the last sentence and for the
support somebody read this and for the
support of this declaration with a firm
reliance on the protection of divine
providence we mutually pledge to each
other Our Lives our Fortunes and our
sacred honor what else do they have to
pledge except those things that's a
pledge of everything right we pledge all
of that and who did they pledge it to
each other
yeah you know the war literature right
people do uncommonly brave things on
battlefields and many many people do it
and most of those people didn't think
they could before they did one of the
themes that emerges from the battlefield
literature is they do it for each other
they don't want to get shot they can't
stand the image of their friend getting
shot can't bear it
they love right these guys are in this
room is actually the room where the
Constitution was written to later
they're in this room and they're
promising each other
see that's a big pledge and a pledge of
everything and in the name of who do
they make this pledge divine providence
yeah who's that
their creator yeah as was mentioned in
the beginning of decoration okay so God
right they swear to God and to each
other that we have returned of these in
Hillsdale collagen I won't say that
they're not sometimes a little naughty
and and they all take pledges owes to
join the fraternity and the O's are all
the same they're all 19th century
Christian organizations these
fraternities and we're big of takers
around here as you know we're just like
these guys right the deck boys Finn Finn
it's so so all you got to do is remind
you of their oath you know what you do
they you know okay well you know what
you promised to do and your oath to your
fraternity and it's always there all of
us are to God and each other many of
them to the college dude that means I
really got right they got a straighten
up now and and that's a it's a big deal
with war pending right and this is
particular right the people in the room
you know about four times as many as is
around this table swear to each other I
swear to Emily and Emily swears to me
and that means later we don't do it we
know the name and can picture the face
of the person who's going to disapprove
who's been betrayed right and that's as
particular as it can possibly get but it
begins was a Casey you said that
universally that wasn't once garrison
good job yeah it begins universally it
begins without reference to any place or
any people but to every place and every
people and it ends with the utmost
particularity you know if you think
every choice you make
you've always got some sense of right
when you make a choice
this document moves from this ultimate
sense of right that we all carry down to
the particular circumstances in which
they are going to act right now and the
whole document is a connected chain from
the general to the particular and it's
exactly the process every one of us goes
through every time we make a hard choice
that interesting
yeah and and what are they doing except
making a really hard choice what's in
the middle that connects the very
beginning the universal part with this
final conclusion that they make is the
list of particulars and so what kinds of
things are those imposing taxes on us
without consent quartering troops homes
dissolving representative houses
repeatedly think of those all three of
those are the same thing all three of
those are failing to represent they put
their troops up in our houses which
means they're taking our houses when
were we going to live right and they
disband the legislature and we're gonna
talk about these more when we get to the
Constitution but I mentioned them here
now because there's actually an outline
of the Constitution of the United States
in the middle of the Declaration of
Independence it's an amazing thing and
the chief elements of the Constitution
are listed here in the negative sense
that the king violated them